y tú
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es verdad que el que se han esforzado
bastante por esa próxima
[Música]
en su caso no creo que consiente
si ha sido usted
así que voy a dar una segunda
oportunidad porque como docentes es
valorar todo lo que se produce y además
intentar colocar así que por favor puede
volver a dar nosotros
[Música]
ahora
si hubiesen sabido esto
seguramente alguno hubiera puesto un
poco más de esfuerzo porque al final del
esfuerzo en donde parece es lo que tiene
que ser es más
[Aplausos]
incluye así que es imposible que le
pongo ya lo siento
pero es más si hubiera visto estos
instrumentos sabrían además al menos
tendría que estar durante 30 segundos
aprendiendo además tendría que he
utilizado en la voz silbando etcétera o
haberse puesto de pie si es que quiere
ver
bueno el problema lo tenemos es que
debería dejar que esas fuerzas
porque parece que esforzarse es
suficiente en este proceso
si yo lo que quiero además es aumentar
el nivel de simiente de nuestros alumnos
puede utilizar otro tipo de instrumentos
como estos que han ido evolucionando a
los anteriores que se han denominado
públicas y que además permiten tener
mayor nivel de eficiencia a la hora de
valorar lo plano nuestro trabajo debería
ser otro y es intentar predecir los
ángulos con claridad qué es lo que
tienen si realmente queremos que tenga
un buen resultado
pero el problema es que con el paso de
los años nos ha hecho creer que tener
muchos alumnos que tengan resultados
excelentes hace que seamos malos
profesores porque enseñan llamado davos
con una campana que famosa dijo algo muy
importante y es no se puede tener muchos
buenos porque si no las sensaciones que
somos buenos profesores así que tenemos
que intentar mover todo el proceso para
que la gente tenga una sensación de que
tras un esfuerzo enorme el resultado ha
sido poco para que el profesor en
realidad no sea
porque estricto es aquel que suspende
mucho aunque se haya realizado un mundo
en este proceso no parece que la cosa
vaya muy bien así que si me permiten voy
a ponerles dos paradojas relacionadas
con el esfuerzo
una vinculada con él
y otro vinculado con el esfuerzo y el
emprendimiento que siempre viene bien
para él
seguro que recuerdan emblemático sobre
todo porque el paradigma del esfuerzo es
el propio
nunca ha habido nadie que se esfuerce
tanto por conocer a los correcaminos y
sin embargo nunca mobiliarios así que
algo no tiene que estar relacionado ante
el esfuerzo y el rendimiento porque si
no ya lo habría donde veces
pero bueno
y haríamos cuanto correctamente
y unos cuantos pero el sistema
la historia cambiado mucho porque ahora
como tenemos que tener a todos los
centros educativos ahora tenemos un
montón de coyotes y los correcaminos
tienen que quedarse escondidos no vaya a
ser
así que la historia ha ido cambiando
mucho y en este proceso al final siempre
acaba ocurriendo lo mismo que un entorno
competitivo siempre
el capítulo que al final siempre y otros
que miran de tarde
tenemos un sistema educativo extremo
muy de hecho nos pasamos el día llenando
nuestros alumnos de contenido para que
cada tres o cuatro meses
para que conduzcan algo de todo lo que
han metido para que dé la sensación de
que han aprendido algo
no se rinden porque en realidad la mitad
o la mayoría de las cosas y además por
qué
así que desde esta perspectiva igual
deberíamos replantearnos todo el proceso
que estamos llevando a cabo porque al
final algunos no son capaces de mostrar
en ningún caso una buena competencia
por eso aparecen los importantes lanzar
las cosas grandes ayudan a conseguir que
la gente que no produce
yo soy en esto el hombre soy yo en
realidad nunca llegó el periodismo el
baño nunca me opuse por detrás a ver si
en algún momento ha cambiado la
composición nunca miro las revistas para
ver si han cambiado la foto yo soy
simple
y sin mucho esfuerzo consiguen
resultados
sin embargo yo viví con uno de esos que
eran los que más se esforzaban en
hacerse eso decían los vecinos del
segundo y de sexto puente porque después
de comer y aunque aquello no era normal
ese nivel de esfuerzo
pero la pregunta es esta porque la suya
tiene que valer más que la uña porque se
ha esforzado mágicamente
y en realidad el principito
nada dos músicas
es exactamente lo mismo si uno tiene
alta capacidad y no le cuesta mucho
conseguir un buen resultado tiene que
poner cara de esfuerzo para que después
el que nos llega pero te pone esfuerzo
recuerde una cosa
cuando llegas antes es porque no
funciona bien esto y sigue sin funcionar
así que es el momento de darnos cuenta
de algo importante esos instrumentos que
hemos al principio son instrumentos muy
importantes porque permiten comprobar
nivel de competencia
así que algunos aunque algunos muy bien
descubrirá viendo esto porque cuando el
baño si no hace lo que debe de hacer
para conseguir unos resultados pero no
sé
has tenido sigue extendido con las
piernas como responde a la inclinación
que ponga incluso algunos crearles con
estos instrumentos son muy útiles se
puede incluso ya aprovechar para ser
ecológicos
y que la gente que utilice menos papel
será premiada
si cambiamos y pasamos a otro punto de
vista nos daremos cuenta que si seguimos
teniendo bastante el problema está en el
sistema de consigo pasa algo parecido
aunque los alumnos tengan claro qué es
lo que tienen que hacer y cómo tienen
que hacer tenemos un problema vinculado
a esto y es que algunos alumnos
necesitan mejorar desde otra perspectiva
y la otra perspectiva es un cambio
metodológico la única manera conseguir
cambiar la manera en la que enseñamos
y es una manera de cada alumno se
involucra proceso de aprendizaje e
involucrarse en el proceso de planta que
significa que la manera de transmitir el
pasivo no tiene mucho sentido así que
voy a intentar ponerle un par de
ejemplos que nos permitan diferenciar
entre lo que es la capacidad y lo que es
la competencia
también deben cuando todos ustedes son
capaces de saltar la tumbadora
ya sé que la mayoría piensan que en esta
vida en ese siguiente pero en realidad
capaz uno es a partir de los 78 años el
problema es que la mayoría ni son
competentes lo serán hasta que no
yo nunca ha tenido unos atracadores pero
tampoco tengo un alumno que no hagamos
la obra con tres pelotas que aumentan
así que en realidad
ser competente tiene una relación
directa con el hecho de utilizar también
todos los días que permita cambiar el
proceso de construcción de la ciudad así
que voy a poner un participó que van a
ver o que van a representar
perfectamente esto que él es difícil
le presenta a la luna
yo tengo la suerte que por eso lo
conocemos
el problema es que a la derecha
en este caso tenía la percepción en su
cabeza de que ni siquiera tenía la
capacidad para poder hacer este elemento
utilizando metodologías diferentes con
carácter eminentemente cooperativo
descubrió que si era capaz y que además
tenía la competencia para ello con lo
cual su perfección sobre sí mismo cambió
radicalmente
el caso de alejandro que voy a presentar
a continuación es un caso diferente
-alejandro posiblemente debería estar
aquí
con el tiempo
ah
y están entre ellas mismas estabas y por
lo tanto cuando le planteé hacer el
trabajo de compradores decidió sentarse
cuando comprobó que no solamente la cama
de hacer malabares con tres pelotas y
resaltar la comba doble su perfección de
sí mismo me cambió y cambió la creencia
de que no tenía la capacidad que en
realidad sí tenía y además pudo
demostrar la complot eficaz con lo cual
no tuve que hacer ningún tipo de
adaptación para qué
si era un tótem
así que
como resumen de todo lo que estoy
haciendo y para cambiar el proceso de
aprendizaje real y conseguir generar un
proceso de educación inclusivo en el que
no tengamos que ir perdiendo coyote por
el camino constantemente si queremos
empezar a cambiar no debemos cambiar
internamente la metodología
debemos cambiar un proceso en producción
hacer los planos y determinar que quiero
que entre y decir con un instrumento que
en proceso de evaluación formativa
cuando descubramos que nuestro alumno
tiene un problema a la hora de aprender
y aunque no saber cómo se introduce la
metodología esas metodologías que
introducirán los ángulos en el proceso
de aprendizaje y permiten que formen
parte de su propia
y eso me ha permitido una cosa quizás la
más importante a día de hoy que
demostrada adquisición de competencias
de aprender contenidos que están en los
libros y que van a seguir estando o que
cambiarán dentro del mismo tiempo y
adquirirlas realmente aquellas
competencias que son transferibles para
la vida activa
y parece que una de las competencias más
habituales es la de exponer realmente
y desde luego lo que está claro es que
un alumno de 3º de primaria debería
normalmente también en sexto en primero
de la eso en cuarto en bachillerato y la
universidad pero el nivel de competencia
no es el mismo en todos los casos y
deberíamos
cuál es el nivel de competencia que
queremos
el pp permite que si no establecemos con
claridad cuál es la secuenciación de las
competencias para poder conseguir
determinar hasta dónde queremos llegar
sin embargo
de los alumnos podríamos establecer que
diferentes profesores que levantas y un
mismo alumno tienen el mismo tipo de
feedback 4 presenta exposiciones en
diferentes contextos algo que no sé es
que no deberías estar complicado si no
pusiéramos de acuerdo alguna vez para
hacer cosas como una introducción
y eso sin duda la mujer el cambio de
nuestro un cambio de actitud del alumno
en cuanto a lo que es capaz de hacer y
lo que no y por lo tanto comprobar que
no hace falta generar entornos
competitivos para
muchos compañeros que me dicen que
utilizar este tipo de instrumentos y
ayudar tanto a los alumnos es
facilitárselo demasiado
pero tiene un trabajo
este demuestre que le permite y ese
aprendizaje tenemos que ayudarnos a
nosotros a que lo adquieran por eso
quizá como visto la marca mediante
resuelve todo este proceso sí porque
tenemos la de las actitudes
la fe de las competencias
todos los días y la devaluación así que
después de usted no podría estar tan
equivocado el problema es que cada día
hacía un experimento diferente y nunca
descubría porque el anterior no había
funcionado
y si vamos un paso más allá y para
aquellos compañeros que tengo que a
veces me dicen que es demasiado trabajo
en que el objetivo es que tengamos
nuestros hijos nos daríamos cuenta que
las cosas cambian exponencialmente
cuando bueno tenemos casi nunca genera
proceso de competición en tres puntos
básicos porque sabemos que si intentamos
que nuestros hijos demuestren tienes el
mejor con respecto a los cuando
lleguemos a la adolescencia
uno de nuestros hijos desaparecerá así
que si en mi casa lo que busco es pero
si mis hijos oradores se ayuden consigan
resolver problemas de forma conjunta
trabajo con un objetivo común aunque la
sociedad sea muy competitiva no creo que
esto
qué
menos competidores menos capaces de
superar los problemas de la sociedad así
que si en nuestra casa lo hacemos
deberíamos hacer lo mismo como estos
algunos en clase sólo tenemos que pensar
que nuestros alumnos son nuestros hijos
y como yo
así que si quieren que yo les ponga
buena nota
recuerden un poco es muy importante la
primera
segundo el ritmo
en la donación tiene que ser superior a
30 segundos porque si no qué tipo de
aplausos es en el cuarto es que si no
sirve griten y si no engancha de bien
porque si no los pies no se va a mover
así que muchas gracias intenten siempre
pensar que la educación debe ser
inclusiva competir dentro de los
procesos educativos no generan realmente
más motivación aprendizaje sobre todo
cuando ustedes por sus hijos son los
últimos
[Aplausos]